gosh it is I have to say it is a great
looking watch and I didn't get that
really from the presentation so I guess
your your video is even better than Tim
Cook's was what surprised you the most
about your test drive of this watch you
know I think one of the most surprising
things was that it does a lot of what
your phone does I mean you know you can
make calls on it you can send text
messages on it you can check your email
on it it's it's kind of like a little
phone on your wrist the incident
complaint or the instant concern I
should say after Tim Cook's presentation
was battery life how did you experience
the battery life of this watch I mean
honestly I thought the battery life was
excellent I forgot to mention this in
the review but I charged it every night
and I didn't think about it at all
during the day so I could go through a
whole day not pay any attention to it
and it was fine but what about the
fitness suite I mean does it measure
your heartbeat does it measure how long
you sleep does it measure your steps
yeah it does
it doesn't do sleep but it does all of
that other stuff and what's cool about
it is that it does it in a way that's
really frictionless it'll track all of
that stuff and you can check in on it
but it doesn't force you to engage in
some kind of activity so I mean I'm sure
you have tried out other smart devices
like a jawbone in the Fitbit maybe other
smartwatches like Samsung's how does
this compare to the sort of beginning
level of peers I mean this blows away
other smartwatches it's definitely the
best one you can buy the best one that's
ever been on the market and I think for
fitness bands I mean they're gonna be in
trouble because this is a much more
attractive package and it does all the
stuff that a Fitbit does so if you had
three hundred and fifty nine dollars of
disposable income when you buy it I
would because I spend a lot of money on
stuff that I don't necessarily need I
think it's gonna be a tougher sell for a
lot of people who aren't gonna be
totally convinced that they need this
well what is it you know my initial
thought was for at least grown adults
most people have a nice watch already
you know an automatic timepiece maybe
something your father gave you maybe
something you got at work does this
replace a Rolex or a Breitling or even a
really nice Seiko
I mean in terms of looks I think
traditional watch is still more
attractive than this but it does this
the Apple watch does a lot more than
those watches so it's a big trade-off
you know do you want a beautiful
timepiece
that's a Swiss movement that's gonna
last for a hundred years or do you want
cutting-edge technology that does a
thousand different things on your wrist
I mean you really have to be able to
make that distinction and decide based
on those factors